[Music]  amazon is getting ready for its annual  prime day  sales the online discount day typically  happens in july but was pushed back this  year  the sales start at midnight and run  through wednesday  last year members purchased more than  175 million items  shopping experts say this year could  feature big discounts  on smart home devices tvs and laptops  amazon has promised to help out small  businesses as part of its  prime day push but many are having to  get creative to keep sales going  especially with the holidays around the  corner some stores are doing virtual  shopping over face time  for those not comfortable going inside  others are offering black friday deals  for longer to compete with major  retailers